[Applause]
combos and fighting games indicates a
sequence of moves which produce a series
of hits that leaves the opponent unable
to block or otherwise avoid the
following hits in the sequence
in tekken execution and combo knowledge
is part of what makes a player good it
can help you win the game easily or it
can cause you the game just by simply
dropping it
oh he got it
oh no
oh no this is gonna be it i think he's
here are some of the craziest combos
done by professional players in tekken
tournaments that are kind of difficult
to pull off even in practice mode my
name is drew and you're watching ochoto
tv
discord
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
okay he's feeling good right now oh yeah
he's feeling good right now he's
loosening up
get the linoleum
here we go
oh double
off the side step two
you're gonna kill here
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
well i have never seen that wow what is
going on
what is going on wow
but we have seen him make some miracles
happen in the background
let's see what he's gonna do here be
careful
again
oh my god character in this game yo good
split kick here from
man
oh
oh
it's party time
oh my goodness
he probably had a slimmer right he might
have a sliver
oh my god oh my god let's go
what is going on what are we seeing here
crazy combos from me here in the finals
in the first round
he's going to take him to the wall for
sure
[Applause]
way to make the crowd
and just like that saint is turning it
around toby's not done here comes the
oh and he cancels and it sends him
downstairs he's got rage available as
well
this is dude
what a combo they're gonna kill it's
gonna scale like crazy but it might it
kill oh my god
what a combo that's going to be on the
highlight oh my goodness safe
thanks for watching be sure to subscribe
[Music]
[Music]
you